more its Hearts who's going to be
talking about is your model predicting
the past
thank you
thank you very much yeah so this will be
short this is kind of a chaser to
juanki's talk so um if you watch this on
YouTube uh you know first of all uh hit
like And subscribe uh show uh the
Simon's Institute our uh sponsor for
today some uh appreciation also uh click
on the video uh that uh huangki just um
you know um okay or the talk that Juan
could Escape so
um this will be self-contained but it'll
make more sense it'll resonate more with
you after this uh wonderful talk so what
is this about okay so if we'd like zoom
out a little bit and we try to like
figure out what sort of we're really
talking about at this Workshop it's
about predictions about when we should
use predictions about how we should use
prediction and so here is what I think
is really core to many normative debates
about prediction in fact not new
um it's this question of when are we
justified in using statistics to decide
about individuals okay and this is a
political Battleground and has been
since at least Italy and his social
physics from the 9 18th century and the
idea that you know human populations are
distributions and they follow laws and
that these laws are some kind of
normative Benchmark that you judge
individuals against these statistical
laws
um that sort of led to you know Galton
and the eugenesis to sort of make that
uh normative Benchmark like something
that you wanted to improve upon and so
this is like it's been going on for a
while right and we're still in this sort
of uh debate in my opinion right it
hasn't changed
um all that much if you go back in
history and so we're talking about like
this sort of tension between aggregate
patterns that we find in distributions
and individual life trajectories right
and so proponents always do this kind of
like sleight of hand proponents of
prediction whereby they say that um
these statistical risk scores really
give you a look into the future of an
individual life trajectory and I want
you to sort of critically examine your
typical argument in favor of a
predictive tool it always hinges on some
implicit assumption like that that we're
forecasting an individual life
trajectory and hence we're entitled to
intervene in that person's life for
instance by like you know putting them
in jail uh in uh preparation for their
trial right but if we're not predicting
an individual life trajectory if we're
maybe just predicting what school you
your parents chose for you the whole
sort of argument in favor of prediction
kind of breaks down right and so
um this is what sort of others point out
that well prediction punishes or can
punish individuals for circumstances
outside of their control and things that
predate their own agency okay
um and so um in this room there have
been many uh in this or multiculturation
Community to ask or what are individual
predictions right how do we get better
at making like these individualized
highly individualized forecasts and in
my opinion multi-calibration sort of a
framework to
um you know approach this ideal of an
individual prediction whereby you you
just kind of make your predictions more
and more fine-grained until you can
really treat them like individual
forecasts and then every thing sort of
works out
I'm going to do the opposite in this
talk I'm going to ask what is blatantly
non-individual okay so I'm going to ask
what predictions are not about the
individual but rather about their
environment and when are we actually
predicting the environment and you saw
in quantities talk one beautiful example
so I'm going to give you sort of a more
General way to think about that okay
so this distinction between an
individual versus environment is
certainly also not new um it's actually
fundamental to the theory of equality of
opportunity and one um you know line of
work I really admire in this space is
John romer's formal definition of
equality of opportunity from uh you know
the late 90s
um which basically says so much as to
say um you know equalize Rewards or
equalize allocation based on individual
effort
um relative to the individual's type
okay he's saying if you're in the 90th
percentile of effort
relative to your type which I'm about to
tell you what that means
um you know you should be entitled to
the same outcomes regardless of time
okay so the 90th percentile of effort
always gets the same regardless of that
okay and so
um this all hinges on you know effort is
sort of the more uh easy part to Define
right it's like maybe your test scores
or something like that how much work you
put in these are sort of the individual
features but what is Type okay and and
vermer actually like spends a lot of
time over the years sort of going back
to this definition revisiting it in
light of like new understanding and
here's something he wrote in 2000 he
said a type groups individuals of
similar circumstances where
circumstances are those aspects of one's
environment including perhaps one's
biological characteristics which are
Beyond one's control okay and so for
instance one thing he struggles with
when it comes to type is is is race at
part of the type right or is that like
an individual feature so it's a
challenging distinction to make but it's
absolutely fundamental to this this kind
of theory and this our our understanding
of equality of opportunity okay and so
I'm going to be a little bit more
pragmatic about it okay and I'm going to
lean on sort of the crutch of time okay
and I'm going to sort of bootstrap this
distinction between individual
environment just using the idea of like
what came earlier okay so
um I will say though that like this
whole theory of like social
constructionism uh you know certainly
challenges this distinction between
individual environment right like what
is Prince's religious affiliation right
that's like some like Collective
practices of your parents and they
baptize you when you're early or
something right is that really you're
doing or is it your parents doing or
your environments for doing you know who
knows right so it's a con uh it's a
social construct and as such it sort of
blurs this kind of line right
um but let me try to approximate it for
the purpose of this talk because we're
like kind of pragmatic machine learning
people uh with just the help of time and
that's why we called it you know
backward
um baselines or you know backward uh
features
um we're asking sort of what are the
features in your problem that came
before the individual's agency okay and
our hands sort of outside the
individual's uh control okay and so
examples are uh your age race
biologically signed sex place of birth
various decisions your parents made like
which school you go to Etc okay and
we'll we'll be sort of like
a little bit fuzzy about exactly what we
throw into the the background features
okay so it depends a little bit on the
on the application that we have
sometimes it makes sense to include sort
of all demographic features things like
marital status even if like that's
technically something you can you know
manipulate okay
um good so what am I going to do in this
talk I'm going to try to
um convince you that this distinction
between individual and environment is
absolutely fundamental to our discourse
about prediction and I'll tell you a
little bit about how you might go about
defining it
um and how to evaluate it empirically
and then we'll look at some data sets
and see how that plays out and then I'll
end on like a discussion of how this
should sort of inform our uh debates
around prediction and risk scoring and
and then the use and limitations of of
prediction in various settings okay
people still on board good
great
formal setup okay
and by the way this is Joint work with
Michael Kim in case I missed it in the
beginning over my YouTube announcement
so whenever I get stuck
um you know I will point to Michael for
help
um so um you know uh and you should ask
all the tough questions to Michael okay
um so formal setup it's a standard just
prediction setup the one we've been
using uh throughout this Workshop so you
have like jointly distributed uh random
variables X and Y expressing features
and a targeted variable and you look at
a standards of risk minimization setup
where you're trying to minimize some
loss function over a fixed uh
distribution uh and we'll typically just
uh look at a loss function that's either
squared loss when you talk about
regression or zero one loss when we talk
about classification okay and um you
know just to recap we've seen that
you've seen this many times the optimal
solution to this problem uh if you're
unconstrained is the conditional
expectation of Y given X in the case of
squared loss and in the case of cr1
unless you rounded okay and that gives
you a classifier that minimizes this
loss
it will generally designate these
background features okay so um Juan can
give you an example of like what you
know background features were in the
case of Wisconsin public schools and it
depends a little bit on the on the
application that we have what
constitutes background and I'll denote
these features by uh the letter W okay
and I think of X as sort of all your
features so I assume that W is
measurable with respect to X so you can
like you know knowing X means you know W
okay so uh X encodes everything and W
sort of uh more coarse uh description of
the individual
so um you know before Avi leaves the
room this is just for illustration it's
not it's not part of the formal setup
it's just for the people in this room
who like causal diagrams
um I actually you know uh through this
causal diagram and it's it's um I made
it prettier by uh you know giving it a
Time access below and we sort of
interpret this causal diagram like uh
over the course of time where these
background features are sort of like
assigned first and then they have a
chance of influencing the individual
features and the outcome okay so they're
confounding the individual features and
the outcome and
um you know X is uh is sort of directly
might directly influence the outcome how
much effort you put into something Etc
um but this is maybe a helpful way to
illustrate it okay
is the formal setup clear nothing really
has happened I'm just like throwing in
an extra random variable okay and so
this leads uh to this definition of
backward prediction
um where we say that a predictor f is a
backward predictor if uh f is or f of x
is conditionally independent of Y given
W okay
um does that ring a bell
this is basically what huangki talked
about okay just so this is like
um uh you know when we when we did this
is sort of the the deuce thing wasn't
quite as clear to us and then it was
actually like interesting to see this
pop out of dues so we didn't sort of
hack it you know it's just kind of like
uh you know and sometimes Michael and I
theorized this and then we saw it in
like the deuce case like pop out very
clearly actually much more clearly than
I had expected so I didn't think that
this would sort of ever be as crisp and
and in a practical setting okay and so
um the way I think about this is that
conditional on background scores look
random okay so conditional on on on uh
on your on your background W the scores
are just you know a random variable that
has no has no signal okay
um again you could look at just sort of
the optimal uh you know solution based
on only the background features this
would be just the conditional
expectation of Y given W
um and see same for for the uh zero one
loss so we can in general talk about
like what is optimal given w
and we'll use that and as an example
deduce risk score as you just saw is
independent of student Dropout
conditional on school okay so the a Do's
risk score is a background uh a backward
predictor okay
um and I think of also backward
prediction as like sort of blatantly
non-individual right and I I sort of
think of this as kind of a TCS move uh
that I learned from the TCS Elders that
if you're struggling to define a concept
you should start by defining what is
blatantly not the thing you're trying to
Define okay so this is a lesson I
learned from like Omar and Cynthia and
this is like what you should be doing I
might be doing it wrong but I was trying
to sort of approach this question of uh
individualized Risk by sort of imagining
what is the opposite what is blatantly
non-individual okay and so this is
trying to get an answer to that so I
like this picture right so here's the
world according to backward prediction
okay it's Omega
well but I think sort of you know um
again I will interpret it liberating so
the question is why is you know School
background if it's like technically
after your birth that's why I said we'll
we'll sort of like you know uh things
that are so plausibly outside your
agency right the decision your parents
made for you right or a decision that
sort of is strongly constituted by your
environment
um good uh your parents choose where you
live that narrows down the school you
can't just go anywhere et cetera right
um good so here's what the world looks
like uh to a to backward predictor okay
as uh in our example there's the 0.5
school and there's the point nine school
and there's the point one school and you
can go to the point seven school but
given that you go to the point seven
school you know I learned nothing you
know naughty is a point three Emily is a
0.7 it means nothing I just look at it
and it means nothing to me and this is
sort of interpret this from the
perspective of the teacher you know I
walk into the school presumably I know
where I am okay I know I walked into the
point seven school okay I know I'm not
in this school right so by the time the
teacher walks through the door all uh
signal is resolved so at that point the
teacher only sees like random numbers in
the classroom right there's no like no
more signal in it it's just like it's as
if you're staring at like a random like
labeling of the students
so I guess the this prediction is
independent of your individual features
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
like the like what happens if there's an
intervention is
so like the teacher looking at excellent
point Charlie
um so um hold that thought so what what
does it say about intervention okay um
excellent point okay
um okay
um and this is like this is I'm
extracting you know this observation
from this paper with uh Solani and ready
um here's the thought experiment you
need to do okay and it needs some
assumptions but then it actually says an
awful lot about intervention actually
says almost everything
suppose now like a setting of the
background features defines a unit uh
like a school right so I'm like
to find well-defined social group okay
and assume the following assume the unit
has at its sort of uh this tense uh an
intervention that improves uh the
outcome at a fixed cost okay so schools
have a budget and they have some they
know some set of interventions let's say
one it could be great it could be bad it
doesn't matter they know an intervention
that improves the outcome at some fixed
cost okay and let's make one more
assumption let's assume that the unit
Targets this interventions at least as
well as random given its budget okay so
the school uh you know principle assigns
this intervention at least as good as a
random allocation so they're not like
blatantly incompetent they know like
roughly who to like intervene on okay so
they're better than random at least as
good as random okay not necessarily
strictly better but they're like no
worse than just like randomly throwing
out the intervention until the budget is
depleted okay these are two very
reasonable assumptions in my opinion in
most settings under these two
assumptions
it follows that the targeting uh that
targeting the intervention based on a
backward predictor
cannot lead to any Improvement
is that clear this proposition
I'm writing it informally by this
dilemma if you will or like a
proposition okay under these two
assumptions uh that you're uh you have
an intervention of of some strength uh
you can Target people at least as well
as random then
um you know the backward predictor
cannot give you any Improvement why
because the score is random given the
unit okay so at the level of the unit uh
this uh you know targeting based on the
backward predictor is like part at least
only as good as targeting randomly
does that make sense
so the beauty of this argument is I know
what you're thinking you're thinking
well wait a minute it could still be
that interventions work great right and
I agree but I'm saying the backward
predictor wouldn't help you any with a
with the intervention right it could
still be that schools have like an
amazing Intervention which completely
prevents dropout
could be but the backward predictor will
not help you at all in targeting that
intervention
okay
does it make sense
okay yeah this is this took me a long
time like we kept staring at the data
and you know this this sort of had to
grow on us I think like it took us a
while to like figure out that actually
under some very weak assumptions this
resolves the question of interventions
we kept thinking like what about
interventions and like it actually
resolves that question you just didn't
see it at first okay good
um so how can we now get good I'm going
to get into some slightly technical
stuff
um uh it's not super exciting but how
can we measure the strength of backward
prediction
um the first idea that you might have is
just train a predictor based on only
background features see how good it
works I'm gonna just fit a you know fit
a model based on W see how well it works
this is reasonable but it's actually not
the only thing you can do there's
another thing that makes a lot of sense
uh specifically given a risk score given
somebody presents you with a risk score
like to do a score you can train a model
based on W not to predict the outcome
but to predict the score okay so you can
ask like how well can I predict uh the
the model f given something that only
uses w and the appeal of that is that it
doesn't even need the target okay you
don't even need the outcome you don't
need to wait around until students have
either graduated or not you can
instantaneously sort of check uh how
much their background prediction is
going on
okay so this does not even need Target
variable access and as a result it sort
of makes auditing a lot easier you don't
even need outcomes okay
and so um oops
okay so let's let's give them some
notation so I'm going to use these
triple notations so of yeah
is that related to like in cause
just measuring compounded
yeah yeah I think you can sort of uh you
know uh if you think of the W as a
confounder right you want to know how
much like you know yeah yeah
I mean a lot of these things you know
this is this is relatively because the
setup is like you're just introducing an
extra feature right so all sorts of
things are gonna be like formally
equivalent I'm just interpreting it in a
certain way
um and just context okay so let me give
some notation for this um I'm going to
call it xyy at the experiment uh you
know where you train on data generated
from X and Y and you evaluate on the
target uh uh why okay and uh there are
four other things you could do okay you
can train on Wy and evaluate on y
um you can train on you know Wy hat so
you train to predict the predictions uh
and then you evaluate on the true labels
this is the the second thing I mentioned
but you can also choose to evaluate on
something else okay so you can uh you
can choose to evaluate on on the
predictions and serve the target then
you get this y uh wyy hat where you
train on the true labels and then you
evaluate on the predictions and finally
the other reasonable thing that you
could do is you can train on the
predictions and evaluate on the
predictions okay
um so these are the four things just
sort of like mechanically the things you
could Implement in in in SK learn okay
so you can like you know if you imagine
fit and predict you know this is like
you just plug in the labels those are
remember it okay so there's four things
you can Implement with fit and predict
you just put one thing in fit and the
other and predict okay and so uh this is
this is uh this is how I I remember this
okay
um this is a little bit sketchy but okay
um good fortunately things
um uh simplify a little bit assuming uh
the predictor is weekly calibrated uh
According to some Michael Kim definition
of weekly calibrated
um it's actually
um these the space collapses a little
bit so why why sorry wyy is equal to
wyhead Y and Wy hat is equal to W I had
y hat and so it only matters what you
evaluate on okay it only matters what
you put in the third letter and it
doesn't matter what you put in the
second okay
you can think about why that is it's
actually a good exercise for the
calibration Geeks okay
um or you can just like do it in Python
and see that it's true which is what I
did okay so um and so also the other
thing is for squared loss it gets even
easier because for squared loss uh the
sort of xyy uh a loss is equal to uh the
y y uh the wyy squared loss minus the w
y y hat squared loss okay so these
things kind of add up to the same thing
now he's getting nervous
Spectrum the population level of things
population
is all at the population level
yeah good and so let's look at empirical
evaluations
um and so here we actually evaluated
backward baselines so these like four uh
four ways of doing it on uh large
longitudinal uh panel surveys
um and why did we go to panel surveys
um part of the real reason was that um
panel surveys so these are surveys that
survey the same individuals over
multiple time windows they're usually
very precise about the temporality of
the variables okay and they very cleanly
separate sort of demographic variables
from like things you did in a certain
time period and that sort of gives us a
very clean empirical evaluation and
actually as a side note go to your
favorite machine learning data set and
try to find out if the target variable
came before or after the features
and finally it's like it's often not
clear at all if you have something like
fraud detection are we looking at
transactions where fraud has already
occurred or looking at transactions
where fraud had then occurred okay
um little sort of side note that like
machine learning people usually don't
even document whether we're predicting
something that has already happened or
something that's going to happen panel
survey sort of solved that problem
because they're very clear about it
that's why we use it
um and so uh one uh big well-known uh
panel story is the medical expenditure
survey Maps uh it's a large longitudinal
survey of individuals households and
Healthcare Providers
um and it's aimed at providing insights
into Health Care utilization we turn
this into a prediction tasks by
basically taking the feature from one
wave of the survey and the outcome
variable from another wave and here in
this case we looked at everything that
was designated demographic by the survey
um and we at the Target variable we took
some threshold of Total Health Care
utilization in a year okay so the data
is basically a bunch of demographic
things a bunch of things you like
medical uh doctor visits you did in a
year and then your Total Healthcare
utilization at the end of the year okay
which we're kind of addicted
good what happens here is the summary of
all these things
um so these These Bars are the different
bass lines so blue is the the real thing
where you take all the features red is
where you or the middle is where you
take um you know you just train a
predictor based on W of the outcome and
orange is where you uh you predict uh
the label okay
and so what do we see if you just take
age that already like gets you like a
pretty good predictor so Healthcare
utilization age makes sense if you throw
in a race alone gives you a little bit
of signal agent race is pretty good you
take all demographic variables
um you basically get most of the way to
the the all features okay it's not as
striking as dudes but it's similar that
like taking uh all demographic features
gets you basically uh closes the Gap
with uh you know all features okay so
most of the signal doesn't come from
what you did in a year but from what had
already happened a long time ago five
minutes okay great okay
um and so this is for three different
models logistic regression grading
boosting and random Force
Emily
that was all features
features at the stage this is the second
Baseline where you evaluate on the
predictions
this is evaluated on the true labels is
evaluated on the predictions
so this is the thing you could compute
by only having predictions and no
outcomes
good so you see it's not maybe not quite
as striking as as Do's but although it's
like pretty close most of the signal is
in background
all right and you do get very little
power out of like things you did in a
year
um here's the same thing for square loss
it's just sort of similar except that
now random guessing is just like 0.25
and now you see this fact that I claimed
which is that the orange the red minus
the Orange is the blue okay so this is
what I claimed that for for like squared
loss there's really only one thing right
or like two things you know the red
minus the orange it's the blue and so
you didn't you can forget about one of
them
so for square listings are very simple
okay
questions about these plots now do you
look at the puzzled
I didn't divide the square loss by 0.5
this is how I roll you know
not any speechless I've never seen that
you can also look at uh you know RC
curves
um and you you just as a visualization
of how predictive background features
are you know and you see
the for all demographic these curves are
pretty fat
um it doesn't have to be that the orange
thing is below the blue for a reason
that you can think about it okay there's
another
um panel survey I'm going to wrap it up
soon another panel survey sip
um serve of income and program
participation uh it's again an important
longitudinal survey but done by the US
uh Census Bureau that's yeah
so
sometimes how can it be right like
in a certain age group you know there
are the diabetics and the non-diabetics
how can it be that taking that seeing
the future of diabetes doesn't help
prevention
so
um it's more like you know you should
look at the features I don't think
there's diabetes is on there right so I
think it's more like uh the the sort of
non-demographic features of things like
how often did you go to the doctor right
and so
um yeah
so perhaps the issue here is the future
so with all of these things like one one
uh sort of takeaway that would
discourage is to say what have you
collected even more data wouldn't this
sort of like go away and I you know it's
just I don't think so
like because then you know like yes sort
of the the accuracy levels change but
why would you expect that you know
um if you throw in more demographic
features as well somehow yeah
so these are like these are like Taverna
data sets can you change the training
outcome these are tabular data sets you
pretty much get to get the base error
like I don't think there's any like
fancy like you know uh better model that
would be better accuracy sir can you
repeat your points they were saying
collecting the diabetes you're against
collecting the diabetes feature no no
I'm just saying like this is not the
sort of take you can collect whatever
features you want I'm just saying like
uh then you know give me the features
you want and I'll make the argument
again okay go back to as he's talking
about
no there's no diabetes on the slides
there's uh
in terms of whole world I mean I guess
the question is is it because you're
doing so well for the demographic
features that you know the you don't see
the Improvement because the way you're
scaling things in some sense you don't
see the Improvement by actually
observing the political features or is
it because you're just doing very poorly
anyway so yeah there's just no signal
so I mean first of all like diabetes is
an interesting example because like the
social determinants of Health you know
you can look at Nancy Krieger's book and
we could go on an argument of like how
health outcomes are determined and where
in which bracket we should put them in
place very correlated with environmental
factors but still it is not going to be
determined by uh right right so you know
it's super diabetes like sure you can
think of another feature I feel like
this is part of the question of like
what do we throw in what bucket right
and I feel like I'm very happy for you
to like if you like go and you look at
the map survey and you
chief of future partition right I am not
married to this right I'm giving you an
example of like I'm taking the the
classification proposed by the survey
provider and showing you the the numbers
for that
you can you cannot use like a defeat as
like sort of nagalistic take on all of
this which is you can never rule out
that if you collected all the data in
the world you know accuracy would be
100.
you could it could always be that
there's some like individual feature
like you know the wrinkle on your shirt
right which gives you 100 efficacy you
can never rule that out so it's like
sort of like
you know sure like it's there's also
hypothetical individual features yeah no
no I'm not trying to say that we'll get
to perfect accuracy just if you're
trying to make a point about either
predictor
kind of just predicting the past or
doing nothing interesting I mean it's
doing something very interesting right
like let me actually background
predictors are very interesting they're
almost more interesting than like
individual predictors so okay let me
maybe go to the the Takeover because
yeah yeah so sip same thing happens okay
so let me say why like uh you know
background prediction is actually like a
really fascinating thing and not all
sort of like not interesting right so
um here's the reason right so first of
all uh you know there are sort of four
different kinds of reasons that I can
imagine for why you should care about uh
background prediction the first is well
as a normative reason intervention is
based on backward predictors LK is based
on things that were outside your your in
the individual's control and that's what
runs counter to some of our uh you know
ideas about equality of opportunity
right second
um there's this political and rhetorical
issue of like you know if somebody tells
you they're sort of doing something
because it's an individualized risk
score well you should ask is it a
backward predictor because then that
whole argument falls apart and like
backwards should not be sort of labeled
individualized risk scores right and
then from a policy perspective we did
this whole thought experiment of like
what backward prediction says about
interventions and we found that
interventions based on background
predictors are uh background particles
are no better than random once we
account for the environment
and finally they also like sort of
sociological explanations because they
speak to sort of the social constitution
of outcomes right like if you can really
predict the target variable well from
only like background features that says
the outcome that you're studying is kind
of like a socially constituted and uh
you know that is an interesting fact
that you discovered okay so that's where
I want to leave it thanks
I'm sure there are lots of questions I
want to take most of the long ones
offline but if there's one short burning
question
did you look at the case where you
actually just like so there's this
policy implication of like not being
able to Target interventions
did you ever look at the case where like
for for example the panel data if you
like condition on a specific race and
age whether your predictor is doing
anything within that that's interesting
like you would expect sort of like if
it's a true backwards
just white men at this age then I should
have like an artist
or something like that
um yeah yeah so I mean uh first of all
yeah for just ages race you saw the plot
it wasn't it wasn't all that good when
you do all demographic features yeah uh
you know you get along but not not in
terms of like predicting from those
things but more in terms of like
condition like keeping those things
fixed and looking at your predictor and
seeing like if I condition on the
specific one of those buckets did you
ever look at like the conditional proc
but basically if your score is
calibrated and it's a background
prediction then it's constant in that
case right okay yeah just as a way of
titling something yeah yeah I mean this
is equivalent to one of these things
right yeah I think what that experiment
you're saying is equivalent to 100
they're predicting the labels is
equivalent to like
basically
within each bucket you can shoot the
means if you had enough data it'd be
equivalent to like within each bucket
take the mean look it up
okay thank you Morris
okay so we'll see you back at two
o'clock in this room and uh don't forget
to sign up for a ram session
thank you for all the questions